lin manuel was on here and he was
talking about you know being so
impressed by your singing so
weird to take a chance on someone who i
mean
did you say you couldn't sing or did you
say i don't know well so the reason why
i'm oscar nominated for this role is
because of a friend who lied on my
behalf
and and it's his name is greg miele and
he's a he's a massage therapist in new
york he works on all of like broadway
dancers and singers in new york city and
he's one of my best friends in the world
so lynn was getting massaged one day on
the table and and and he asks greg he
says
hey i have a thing that i want to make
and i might want andrew to do it but can
he sing and greg just immediately
without missing a beat just said oh my
god he has
the voice
is natalie and brulia meet jennifer
hudson meets you know ariana grande and
aretha franklin and lin's like that
seems excessive but
and you know the massage ends and greg
immediately calls me and says hey buddy
can you sing
and uh and he's like because you have to
be able to sing because now my
reputation
and and uh
but we all need friends who can live for
us and now so it's greg miele's lies
that has led to this oscar nomination
which is kind of an amazing thing i
think
[Music]